7 blatant changes that give us all in the concerned 1tens more net income,
because the basic tax allowance is increased by just under 700 euros to
euros up to this amount you do not pay tax.
2tens the telephone sick leave will now be possible without a
visit to the doctor for up to 5 days,
if you have no serious symptoms and are known to the practice.
3tens,
the electronic E prescription becomes mandatory.
This can also be used,
for example,
to get follower receipts reissued without
a practical visit starting in January.
4th AB you have to earn Euro gross monthly to receive a pension point per year.
Were for this nochEurobruttoausreichend 5th new 25 cents
deposit on mixed milk drinks in plastic bottles 6th.
The mini-job limit increases from 520 to 538 euros per month.
7.
Electricity is becoming about 11 percent more expensive because the German
government no longer subsidizes the so-called network charges.
But to stop you from paying,
be sure to use this trick.
This saves me 700 euros a year,
because remind me that you can pick me out for free via tariffs,
the best one for me will also take care of the change completely automatically.
So save money too and find out in one minute,
without obligation,
how big your savings can be because they will come.